it's your wedding day you look so
beautiful happy wedding day thank you
you may kiss your bride
[Music]
so that's my brother's wedding we
decided to go sightseeing the next day
hey I blocked this on for you oh yay
enjoy you want to go
[Music]
I'm gonna have to say the coast is
definitely one of the most romantic
places I've been to in a while
[Music]
and after some sightseeing we go on a
boat and we do a send-off of Carrie and
Diana and it was a blast to see Luca
experience being on a boat first time at
in the sea you're out at sea baby you're
a sailor am I dressed in like this
sailor Luca yeah
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
take a quick break from a vacation real
quick I want to shout out fetch for
sponsoring today's video what is fetch
fetch is a free app where you earn
rewards on literally anything you buy so
the next time you go shopping make sure
to save that receipt that you get and
scan your receipt with the app and watch
yourself earn points on your purchase
you know that old saying you got to
spend money to make money well that's
basically fetch but what if you uh don't
go out and buy stuff and you buy stuff
online well it also works on e-receipts
now the app automatically scans your
email and fetch does all the work and
finds the rewards for you trust me when
I say the whole process is super easy to
use it works for receipts from
restaurants any retail store you like to
go to Amazon and yes it does work for
Mom and Pop stores as well all you need
is a receipt that's less than 14 days
old it's that simple and once you got 5
000 points you can redeem your rewards
for gift cards at Amazon Visa Starbucks
Etc other places anywhere and personally
I'm saving my rewards for Amazon because
it's 2022 I don't go out much to shop
anymore maybe it's because I'm lazy I'm
just like clicking around this is this
is the the exercise I get from my
shopping so definitely saving my rewards
for Amazon I buy everything from Amazon
these days so download fetch now and use
our code Tiff case to get 5000 points
when you scan your first receipt we'll
have a link in the description down
below so make sure to click around and
collect your 5 000 bonus points you're
welcome all right back to Road up all
right today is our last day in Rhode
Island we are headed out after we do
this one last little tour here at these
Mansions this is American new money yeah
American royalty and we're waiting for a
carriage or something like that and oh
it's here okay let me uh import it wait
are we getting on the carriage are we
just Oh I thought we were waiting for
the carriage for us to get onto
followed in her hand oh my gosh it's hot
here it's Black Mirror we are in the
presence of American royalty
back in time we travel back in time look
at these people that's so cute Luca is
laughing at that face he's playing he's
playing with that baby face hey who's
that baby right there
literally the moment we walked in we're
like wow
yeah we literally just took two steps in
we're looking at the floor and then I
worked my way up I'm like
this is cool
[Music]
you pick it up your gown you're the the
rich Madam of the house overlooking your
ball baby where are we
oh you can see the ocean over there
[Music]
all right I wish I had a kitchen like
this this would be my haven oh my God
this one kitchen's bigger than my house
all right so we just finished a tour yes
and I learned a lot about this place and
uh in fact everything I learned about
this place I'll probably forget in about
two days literally
[Music]
literally I got a
I got a box within a box
that looks awesome you want some you
want some
[Music]
all right so after our final stop in
Rhode Island had to have a lobster roll
before we left because we're on our way
to New York now and uh we decided to
stop in Connecticut we actually rerouted
our entire Journey yeah to go through
Connecticut yeah because I'm like if we
we're so close to Connecticut I can
scratch off another state if we could
just take a pit stop here really quick
yeah we rerouted to because we were
gonna go through all of Massachusetts
from Rhode Island but then I'm like no
way let's go to Connecticut and then go
up to Albany so that's what we're doing
checking out Connecticut I stepped foot
in Connecticut
in Connecticut stepping on Connecticut
we're not Luca Luca doesn't get to step
foot because he's sleeping yeah he's
sleeping in the park I'm in the town so
we've got to visit
yeah we're gonna check out the capital L
and Isaac pointed out something
interesting too which in this trip we
went to Boston which is the capital of
Massachusetts we're here in Hartford
which is the capital of uh Connecticut
we're about to go to Albany which is the
capital of New York but we didn't go to
Providence which is the capital of Rhode
Island we're so close though I know we
were close we were like I think 10
minutes away from Providence I feel like
we were there everywhere you go in Rhode
Island you're like 10 minutes away from
something else from everything else
yeah I've been enjoying my time out here
on the East Coast very different from
the West Coast I love being here during
the summer because every time we've ever
been out here well not every time
actually but most of the times when
we're out on the East Coast it's always
cold
so it's really nice to be here in the
shorts and tank top yeah and I've been
enjoying the architecture like
architecture is something I really
appreciate that's why me and Tiff always
go to Europe a lot while we got married
in Paris and stuff like that and we've
never been to New England we've never
ventured into like American like old
money architecture type stuff and so
being here I'm like yeah America's got a
lot of good stuff too I love the food
out here I'm a big Seafood person
oysters Lobster
clams clams are actually raw clams
low-key are better than raw oysters so
if you're into oysters check out clams
because those are
money
all right we took another stop after
driving uh feels like an hour or so yeah
well Luca has been asleep for three
hours this has been that's like the
longest snap since he was a newborn
three hours you slept my baby and he
didn't eat for four hours
crazy anyway okay stop we are in
Massachusetts so that means we hit four
oh wait we're gonna be hitting four
states
by tonight in one day sure we left Rhode
Island early today after lobster rolls
stopped in Connecticut detoured over
there and uh stomped on the ground yep
in Connecticut
now we're in Massachusetts yeah and then
we're gonna our hotel tonight is in New
York yes four states in one day baby you
slept through Connecticut
like where am I I don't know I just want
to see the big sign but I haven't seen
the sign yet
yeah summer in New York then there was
no sign there yeah
I missed a sign
combo
we're in New York
Welcome to New York okay uh okay so we
didn't miss it twice I missed it twice
yeah that's what happened yes okay great
[Music]
all right so we just got into uh where
are we in New York Albany I figured we
should stop by an Italian spot first
thing so now we're at a place called The
Monaco's eating some Italian food I love
the decor in here I totally got like the
old school like Godfather Sinatra kind
of vibe
Tony Bennett kind of Vibes there's a
Tony Bennett room actually there's only
pictures of Tony Bennett all right it is
another morning and today we are in New
York we are in Albany so this is the
state capitol you know I'm really glad
that they closed them I really wanted to
walk up the steps yeah
instead of pretended we're Rocky even
though this isn't Philadelphia I do want
to go to Philadelphia one day because
it's closed due to
structurality but it's dangerous
for me they're just some steps it's one
of those things where you walk on it and
then it just creates a sinkhole maybe
imagine no you can see the edge of the
steps that like they have chipped off
maybe people like you know people that
like step on the edge yeah like this the
most dangerous way you have to step
above like past the end like this okay
anyone's thinking about that when they
walk up steps I don't I do it too
it's okay because I do it
we are now walking around the state
building this is like a haunted house
like if I didn't know where you were I
would say you're in a haunted house you
should walk down here it's crazy down
here wow this is like the most beautiful
State Capitol building I've ever been
here
all those yeah
[Music]
he liked it was you growing up there's a
lot more stairs to go
the grand staircase
I'm gonna hold them I can hold them
[Music]
can you picture the powder wigs around
here
back in the 1700 1800s
it looks like he's enjoying it so much
that was my way of cooling them down
nice very nice he appreciated it
[Music]
foreign
in the background sounds like little
goblins going
[Music]
we have made it all the way to Syracuse
decided to drop by Syracuse University
because they're driving around we're
like what does Syracuse have to offer
for tourists like I guess the university
and then we saw some buildings we're
like oh cool let's park and go look at
them okay what'd you call them
everything looks like Harry Potter to me
up here that's like the only Gothic
architecture reference I have I guess it
actually started raining it's sprinkling
right now but it's like all gloomy and
wet and earlier today I was talking to
Mama and yeah yeah I was talking to them
and then they were like oh yeah there's
a flooding in Dallas and I'm like it
rains in the summer and they were like
yeah like it always rains like there's
always rain like year round
random times of rain and I'm like why
would it rain in the summer oh man I'm
so from California and then Casey was
shaking his leg under the table and I'm
like is that an earthquake he was like
wow you're such a Cali girl that's how
you're gonna grow up maybe if you stay
in L.A true we don't know your future
[Music]
[Music]
his finger he's like stop please
[Music]
you get to live out your college dreams
on the University student with the baby
I haven't done this in a while
this is cool
[Music]
all right so we've been stomping
everywhere we go on this trip we didn't
stop in Rhode Island actually but since
we're in New York now something in New
York all right it's another day in New
York
um we are in Aurora and we are in Aurora
for one person and one person only for
my beautiful mom and what are we doing
here we are visiting the Kinsey trials
all their products uh they are famous
for the Checker design
it's very famous
what's your opinion on all this I don't
know
yeah Mama has her whole house decorated
and decked out of Mackenzie childhood
this is really nice though
oh wait it's what I'll put on it this is
a pinky out kind of table
oh that's true you should you should now
think about it think about it we have
the one this uh what do you saying they
try to make it look like them but they
are not oh the the off-brand the China
brand yeah the
copycats
yeah they're cheaper
[Music]
we're in Buffalo now and we're about to
see Niagara Falls and finally check this
off my bucket list so earlier mama got
to check off Mackenzie Childs from her
bucket list and now it's Niagara Falls
time I'm so excited this is Canada right
over there this is the closest to Canada
I've ever been oh yeah we have to go
visit one day oh my goodness it kind of
just smacks you in the face
foreign
[Music]
ER between US and Canada we're on the
U.S side and we're looking at Canada
beautiful city over there and over here
well we don't really have much of sugar
over here
[Music]
let's get a nice nap
look I have this little sound machine
playing waves while he was napping but
now we don't need it he has a little
thing real
damn
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
it's a crazy line going over the edge
like that without this wait like this
way
all right it is the next day and today
we are going on the maid of the Miss and
that is to go over there where all the
Miss is at this has been on my bucket
list for so long no especially ever
since then um Bruce Almighty oh yeah it
made me want to get on made of
meaningfulness so are made
so fast well that's the way the cookie
crumbles
[Music]
my dress is riding up hey she's riding
up
[Music]
it's too cold
oh you want to get it wet gotcha
get into the water
he's flying up
wow
[Music]
it's literally like you can't come and
see Niagara Falls without doing this
yeah
oh my God that was exhilarating
refreshing just the most magnificent
experience of my life that was so cool
10 out of 10. I loved it yeah I would
love to rewatch this because the entire
time I had my eyes closed you did
because the water's gone
in the eyes
[Music]
this is the closest we're gonna get
oh we're getting sprayed oh the boat
didn't do it this did it
foreign
[Music]